来吧,给大家分享三条超有用的提示词
不过呢,咱们先说点废话,把一些人钱过离出去
就很老会知道我既然这么说,一定是有好东西分享给大家
但是呢,大部分人是听不懂的
所以他会觉得我的人是说说,有什么废话呀,对吧,废了避免的种,我先告诉你啊,赶快
对吧,就是,先说点废话吧,你觉得这个是废话,赶快就离开就好了
其实废话也挺我用的
首先,第一句话,各位
如果你想啊,如果你出生在书乡门地
就是不只你父母有文化,你的家族都很有文化
而且呢,你也不用为吃三发手
那么
大概率,就是极小极小的盒子,对吧,你会走向白鲁,但是大概率你
不会困在台上
祝你拿胖困的人仗
别逼我们大多人枪,是不是
有很多时候,你的期点就是我们的重点啊,就是第一个,那为什么要说第一句话呢
因为第一句话和第二句话相关的,第二句话是什么意思呢
就是
很多时候,造成你现在的这个状态
或者做爱我们的
不是不知
是你既有的成绩
就是你从小的时候就
被安装了一套超的一统
最早操作一种不是
书乡门地的人给你安装的
是你身边的各种人给安装的啊,这套超多一种其实是做爱你
的一个重要的原因
我们不是抱怨啊,就是正式这些是什么存在
这是第二件事情
第三句话呢
你到底能取得什么样的场景
或者是你到底能不能把一个东西用出来
不在于知识的多少
知识多少对你的帮助不是特别大
而是你的系统
就是一个事来了以后你是怎么做的
因为你的
现状去游应的行为吗,行为去游应的认知吗
对不对
他去游应的系统是你像意识的完成的那种动作
而不是你有多少知识,因为有很多知识你存在的人
你只要想掉弄的时候
才会去掉弄他
但是你就算你知道
但是遇到设计的时候
你下一次没用他
那取得结果和你不知道这个知识有什么区别呢,没有什么区别对不对
这三件事有了
所以大概我们说你要学东西
一听是什么
就是
真正能影响你操作系统的动静
有些时候不是知识不再多呀
而是真正能影响你的,哪怕一个特别简单照理,你只要用了
真马用出来
你的生活就会发生改变
而不是说,有人提醒你,就是考试啊,你要是这样
你们以为的打扰不是的
下一次一个动静
真正的生活的变成
的人生就发生改变
好
想办法说完了,我估计人走在差不多了,对吧
来,给大家分享三套提示次
我在直播间给大家分享过
所以老婆就可以等到最后啊
第一个提示很简单,我之前分享过
就是问AI的啊,请你告诉我一个,你认为很重要
很简单
很使用
但是用了以后
就对我的生活
能造成很大改变的
但是被我们打都是忽略的
或者是不知道的
怎么一个人知
第一个提示
第二个提示,在前面这个提示前面
做个生计
请你给我三条
你认为很重要
很简单,很使用
只要用了
就能让我们生活发生很大改变的
但是被大多数人忽略的或者不知道的
人知
请你根据我的情况
对这三条认知进行排序
并且给出如此排序的理由
出来以后麻烦你
把他那个理由和排序全看一遍
好好想想他为什么都排序
理由是什么
乃条动静真的对我有帮助
我说这要尝试,这是第二个提示
比三个提示,在第二个提示的记住上
再进行一步
请你给我
三条
很重要
很简单,很使用
用了,就能被我的
人生发生很大改变
大多数人不知道的会被忽略的认知
请你对这三条认知进行排序
给出理由
然后
对这三条认知进行便知
帮我形成一套知识旁下
如果需要什么,请你帮我不全完善
并且给我一个最好的
和值行动
办本
其实还可以在什么节
现在大家一个专时办的吧
大家用上一个认知,你妈没有提供了
我再给大家分享一个
网织有机的
其实是此办办